how can you increase motivation in your
life what are some health extra health
exercises that you would recommend for
someone who does not have access to gym
equipment and does not want to spend
money on excess items now max there's an
interesting word here excess items
doesn't mean no items right I think
we've already covered that right now
like at home I have I have a stationary
bike so does Ryan I'm not saying you
need to also get one of those but for me
I've determined that that's not excess
to me I ride that three or four times a
week I also have a set of you know
weights like the power blocks and I was
using those this morning so that's not
excess for me I used them
I've pull-up bar I do push-ups I could
get by without those things but it's not
optimal for me so I want to be clear
that I don't think it's inherently wrong
for you to own some sort of home gym
equipment or especially now a lot of
people don't have access to a gym
obviously because they've all been
closed for many months and I've seen
some people use that as an excuse to I'm
going to stop working out until my gym
opens up again that's yeah that's why
it's funny I've actually worked out more
since my gym closed yeah because I got
on like this 30-day it when I found it
on YouTube and it's just pretty much
like a pull-up bar some resistance bands
as always all you need yeah what do you
do max yeah you don't need a lot and
I've been sharing a lot of my home
workouts that I do you know during this
time on my Instagram but one of the I
mean I think this so I'm really excited
about this
I bought a jump rope for the first time
I'm 38 years old I've never in my life
it was like 24 yeah I like this is like
a totally new thing for me but I've been
having a blast learning how to jump rope
and now I'm like actually I've gotten
really good at it
yeah and it's an amazing form of
exercise it's not only so good for your
but for your cardiovascular system for
your lymphatic system it burns a
tremendous amount of calories yeah it's
amazing for your brain I mean the fact
that I'm now like you know rewiring you
know in air quotes my brain to know how
to frickin do this new thing let me ask
you always when I saw a guy jump roping
in a parking lot the other day and my my
first thought and maybe the me being
cynical was like why don't you just jump
why do you need the rope it may be
overly minimalist well do
the the 30-day program there is one
there's like certain days where that
you're supposed to jump rope but the
trainer is like if you don't have a
drill probe just sit there and imagine
and that's a I actually do that I just
imaginary jump rope I'll be like right
check it out now you know me I would
trip on it I fell off my pallet on a few
weeks ago I had no balance at all but
anyway back to the to the jump rope how
long do you do that for I've been doing
it for well at first I was only able to
do it for like you know five to ten
second increments and now I'm able to do
it for like bursts of a minute and it's
really hard to do I bet and I can't do
any of those tricks like you know I'm
literally just like hopping up and down
but but yeah I'm getting better at it
I'm able to kind of like you know it's
more automatic for me and and it's just
yeah it's an incredible again it's
amazing for your brain it burns a huge
amount of calories more so than you know
per time interval more than running more
than biking more than swimming
it's an incredibly you know efficient
way of working out
so that's a great one you could do you
know there's tons of push-up variations
that you can do I have a Haunter in my
kitchen that you know forms a
right-angle I've been doing dips on that
I've been doing air squats I also
recently have taken up boxing which i
think is super fun always challenging
myself you know like learning new skills
I think is super important so I think
the lesson to learn here is if you want
to get by with no equipment whatsoever
you can absolutely have a phenomenal
workout every day you can do pull-ups on
you know whether it's a monkey bar
across the street at a park or I have a
pull-up bar perfect pole bars like 20 30
bucks right and I use it every single
day in fact anytime I go to the bathroom
I just make sure I do 6 pull-ups like it
because it's right there on where our
bathroom doors and as I come back out so
on your average day even if I don't work
out I've done 60 or 70 pull-ups that day
just be just for the sheer fact that
it's become a habit right and so you can
do push-ups pull-ups regular squats with
without weights I have a weight vest so
I'll use that for pull-ups push-ups and
squats as well
those are cool lunges you can do
mountain climbers you can do you know
there's a huge number of variations of
the plank that you can do generally we
won't you want to do is you want to
focus on compound movements so your
which are gonna allow you to get the
most bang for your buck yes so if you
have if you happen to have a weight
laying around you know do less of the
bicep curls and instead
you know maybe do bent over rows if you
can or lunges or even air squats I mean
working your lower body I think is
crucially important just because you
have a huge amount of muscle mass down
there right well speak for yourself I
mean not even not even me personally but
just relatively you know like our legs
are just they're the largest they make
up the largest muscle group in our body
like the lower body and there actually
is just to bring it back to the brain
which is of course you know my passion
there's a really good strong correlation
that has been shown that you know having
stronger legs actually is great for
brain health like there seems to be a
correlation between a higher performing
brain and strong legs yeah